each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
it's been a year to talk about what I'm
discussing with Luca since more than 10
years and I will try to share with you
some of this discussion and some of the
story that we have together so let me
start with two sentences from novel our
rate which the first of all and Sydney
Brenner states that biology needs
causality and abstract data must be
mapped into knowledge who nursed speak
specifically about languages to model
the information flow in biological
systems so the idea was to have language
based technologies to enable modeling in
biology and to try to enhance the way in
which systems are represented and we
start from the basic metaphor that we
discuss it a lot also we do the at very
beginning on the stochastic by calculus
in which each biological entity is
represented as a process or a program
then biological entities can interact
each other so that you have interaction
capabilities and we can represent this
capabilities as interfaces on the
processes on the program and then they
really interact and this interaction is
message passing between processes or
updating of shared variables we have
seen also before models that can can can
have different basic formalisms and then
the dynamics of the biological systems
can be can be described by the running
of this big program and interpreting the
state changes of the program we can
interpret out the biological process
evolved so there have been a lot of for
starting since 1996 we'd work by
Fontanella first of all I apologize
because for sure I will forget to
mention something so the this is what I
I tried to recall so 1996 Fontana tried
to do to model biological dynamic
biological systems by adapting lambda
calculus but what was missing there was
the inherent concurrency that you
observe
coatsy's and a lot of threads active
simultaneously millions of actors that
interact together in order to to to to
to to show the behavior at phenotypical
level then we tried with stochastic by
calculus we do the end after the vents
on and cause you know develop would cap
calculus and also Luca entered into the
game with the brain calculi and bio
ambient and we started discussing at
that time about languages for modeling
biological systems and this discussion
indeed lead also at the at the starting
of of Cosby and after that there are
being a lot of others languages that are
more or less variance and in terms of
the computational model in terms of the
syntax in terms of the specific feature
that they can be present there are tens
of of these of dyscalculia around but in
the experience we are in in this more
than ten years trying to model
biological systems we have a sort of
negative message for this kind of
approaches which is good because when
you have a negative message you start
new research and you try to solve those
those issues and negative messages are
that usually biological knowledge about
the dynamics of the systems is not
available so you have old in the
knowledge you have and you have to cope
with that biological systems in real
cases are very large and the performance
of these former formal methods in terms
of approaching these large systems is
not good enough and finally as we have
seen in the first talk of this session
listing codes to biologists to let them
interpret whether it works or not is
something that is not this is that is
not feasible so there is an issue also
of a usability so what I'm trying to do
now is to tell what what we are doing at
kasbah to try to approach these three
issues and i will start just presenting
yet another one language for modeling
biological system that has not yet a
name so I call it I'll and it tries to
mainly address the issue of of
performance not yet usability still a
language so you have a simplex you have
to write code you have to run it you
have to observe what it comes out from
the state change of the system but it is
quite close to at least intuitively
quite close to what a biologist as in
mine do anything of a system it is based
on formerly a system is a multi set of
multi set of objects each multi set of
object is what is called the complex
which is also something close to the
idea of Kappa calculus but in order to
improve performance what we do here is
considered a complex just a set so we do
not take into account which is the
structure connecting the molecules
inside the set and we have rewriting
rules of these objects that map one
state of the system into another that
are in correspondence one to one with
the main chemical reactions that the
biological systems and ergo so here you
can see an association of two objects
one that contains an E and whatever else
and so here you have utter matching and
another one that contains B and whatever
else and you get a new complex joining
these two guys here and you have
dissociation Association substitution
and a general rule that allows you to
manipulate systems for strange things
that are not classical association and
dissociation of objects they novelty of
these approaches that you can associate
the imperative code with each reaction
that implements site conditions and that
can update variables because indeed here
instead of simple processes sharing Chan
each object us internal variables that
can be updated dynamically and you can
create a new object and things that all
the things that do we have seen so far
the idea here is to have this imperative
code that you can associate with this
reaction and these are all and only the
routes that the languages the language
is compiled into into C sharp so in the
end your mother is a c-sharp program
generated starting from this from this
this reaction so the next point is we
want to run a stochastic simulation so
those elements those reaction rules are
selected stochastically and the basic
idea that is underneath most of these
approaches is that it lets be algorithm
in which a system is represented as a
set of reaction of these forms in which
s 1 SN are the species in the system and
you have em reactions that can
manipulate the system by changing the
abundances of the molecules of each
species after the reaction and each
reaction as a rate constant rate that
determines the the time and the speed
assuming to have exponential
distribution mass action law that drive
these systems and the idea is that you
can define propensities for each
reactions so that the propensity over an
interval of time provides the
probability let be given reaction is
selected to fire and it is the other the
algorithm is as a bottleneck in the
computation of in the update of the
propensity of all the species that in
the original formulation has to be done
at each step whereas there are better
better solution but if we want to remain
exact as this algorithm is with respect
to the to the
to the mass action law we have to cope
with this bottleneck so what we did is
to define a new faster algorithm a 2d
one available that is still exact but it
works using a notion coming from
abstract interpretation on intervals of
values rather than on single values so
what we have here is an approximation
indeed for the amount of species X I in
the system and also an approximation for
the propensity of all the reactions this
election is done by checking on the fly
whether the approximation I did
maintains me in the exact space of
solution or move or move me out if it
moves me out I reject the selection and
I repeat the procedure so indeed it's an
approximation that avoids the
computation of propensity at each step
but when i go out the safe part the
white one here in this picture for the
selection when I go out I recompute the
propensity so indeed this algorithm
computes propensity of reaction only
when this is really needed to be done
and we can and we can prove that it is
still a correct it is equivalent to the
direct method of gillespie it is going
to appear the D algorithm on the journal
of chemical physics where the original
paper bag in SB was presented and these
are some benchmark of the performance of
the language that implements that
algorithm and ER gillespie algorithm and
this is the language with these agreeing
that i showed you in which you can see
that it improves most of the time and
also on this benchmark compared with
dizzy bionet gin at two variants of
Gillespie algorithm indeed z in most of
the times performs performs better and
even better when we use more complex
more complex
kinetics the michaelis-menten in this
case because it is more complex function
and then we compared the algorithm
implemented in l with the algorithm
implemented in a standalone fashion to
which it is past not yet code but just
the chemical reaction to see which is
the other end imposed by the l syntax
and you can see that there is some other
red but it is not it is not dramatic
it's still a language i was saying so it
is it is not yet usable what we can do
for improving on that side you have a
lot of graphical formalisms to represent
biological systems all of them are
different but all of them share the
number the very I number of graphical
symbols that are needed to represent to
represent the system and since you want
to map these kind of things into a
program this language has to be not only
was and you have to know the semantics
of all of these different objects for
writing down your system so what we try
to do is to to avoid the syndrome of a
new symbol after the talk by Andrew
Philip yesterday evening this was
already prepared which is a that Luca
since they're a new thing is new is
really knew when there is a new symbol
this is completely the opposite this is
what we did we do we did and so what we
made is reducing to three hours and five
nodes to model the systems and having an
automatic mapping of these guys this is
how they look like into into something
that can be similar ball observing yeah
this is the manual of the first game by
a tire insert the coin avoid twin dots
and it was clear
so programming language in biology I
think that now needs more biology and
this is because what we do there miss
all the data aspects that is what is
producing in the labs so I think that
this was very inspiring the thought by
Andy this morning to try to integrate in
a language framework both death analysis
and the simulation part that I show it
thank you all Anna of course Thank You
Luca for all the inspiring discussions
on this field for the next 20 s